[Music]
you're clearly a very spiritual person
and you've really gotten into astrology
I am I'm really into I'm actually kind
of good at it I've been able to predict
some of the births of my friends
children based on where the moon is
really you know it's because we had my
my birthday's April 18th
yes I actually I had something made up
it's it's your natal chart I left it
yeah it's right here they brought it out
this is my I was born April 18th and so
they made up my I'm an Aries did you
pick me as an Aries when you first I did
it I'll explain to you why like your
your son is in Aries and that's just
sort of the tip of the iceberg and Aries
the ruling planet is Mars who is the God
of War and I know usually Aries you're
gonna find them being firefighters
policemen they're like they're the
instinctual heroes and to me I don't
know you but to me you seem more like an
instinctual reader and so I didn't I
didn't you know you just said that the
Aries is traditionally just like the
he-man the hero the macho you see me as
a guy who's
gentleman is a fire tend to it book you
see but I look to find where your moon
was because the moon reflects our inner
emotions our emotional life our deep
self and your moon is in Aquarius mm-hmm
which is the sign of the eccentric and
sort of makes a little bit more sense
but the ruling planet of Aquarius is
Uranus so what I know from looking at
this just at a glance is that your
emotions are heavily tied to Uranus
[Music]
you feel good about yourself now true
it's true and you also have Saturn there
and you also have Uranus is on the top
of your chart so your Reynes is full
like you are very good at this
Oh Eddy here enjoying this I just love
it that this started with you're a very
spiritual person whole joke
let me just say that that's all true
when I don't say I'm thinking up but
it's also the sign of the genius like
Albert Einstein and so it's it's most
likely that uh no joke he's like mental
level brilliant you yes according to
your chart and that's really all that's
so cool
thank you you also is this true that you
you can assign an animal you there are
animals that bit people represent yeah
I'm just getting into this but you guys
have probably heard of like your spirit
animals yes I've heard of spirit animal
yeah um and it's an it's a combining
your Western astrology with your Eastern
and so like I'm a wolf
cuz I'm a Taurus and a tiger and that
means it's cool to be a wolf um you're
an Aries and you were born the year of
the rabbit and so you're a llama when my
anus is full and I'm a llama
[Applause]
we had I feel I feel like you can kind
of see it and if we have a photo they
took this off the internet my staff
found this llama
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you